Hi, welcome to this the second session
of the investment philosophies class. In
this session, we're going to talk in at
least general terms about risk. Risk is
a theme in investing. You can't make it
go away. It's a constant source of
debate. And in spite of all of the
movements we've made in finance, there
is really no consensus on how to define
and measure risk. In fact, in this
session, I'm going to desri describe
risk as a double-edged sword. Let me
start with that. I know there are lots
of definitions of risk. Many are
statistical and I think they missed the
point. In fact, much of risk management
is built on the presumption that risk is
a bad thing. It's a negative. I think
the best definition of risk I've ever
seen is the Chinese symbol for
crisis/big
risk. And it's a combination of two
symbols. The first one is a symbol for
danger. The second one is a symbol for
opportunity. Put simply, risk is danger
plus opportunity. Perfect way to think
about risk because it locks the two at
the hip. It says if you want one, you
got to live with the other. Now, we know
which one we want. We want opportunity.
But this definition says you want more
opportunity, you got to be willing to
live with more danger. One way to think
about the discussion of risk and return
we're going to have is when you're an
investor and you expose yourself to
danger in an investment. And the
question you're asking is, how much
opportunity do I need to compensate for
that danger? Using a phrase I've used
before, we're not bungee jumpers in
investing. We don't take risk for the
sake of taking taking risk. We take risk
because we think we can earn a return
that is higher because of that risk.
With that lead in, let's talk about the
different dimensions on which you can
measure risk. When you invest in a stock
or any financial asset, there's price
risk from the price of the asset moving
from period to period. And there's cash
flow risk, which is the cash flows
you're expecting to get on that asset
can change over time be different from
what you expected. So there are two ways
in which investors can think about the
risk in investing. One is as the
variability in its in the price. The
more variable the price, the riskier the
investment. But there are some intrinsic
value. People argue that the prices set
by the market which can make mistakes
that you should be really looking at the
variance in the cash flows you get. So
if you're investing in stocks that the
variance in earnings and dividends
should be what drives you thinking about
risk, price risk versus cash flow risk.
You also have total risk versus downside
risk. We'll draw this contrast more
deeply when we look at the statistical
measure of risk. But total risk looks at
both the risk that you get outcomes that
are worse than expected, which is what
we generally think of when we think
about risk, but also better than
expected. Total risk looks at both
upside and downside. Downside risk, you
focus only on that dimension of risk
where you think you're going to be hurt.
And there's a third dimension which I
think is a pretty critical one in
investing. When you look at investment,
you can look at the risk on a standalone
basis. You can look at Apple or Nvidia
and say this is the risk of investing in
this stock or you can look at the risk
that that stock adds to a portfolio. You
might wonder what's the difference. The
difference can be very large and we'll
talk about why that's become the central
theme in portfolio theory. The way we
think about risk being the risk added to
a portfolio.
So let's get the process started with a
couple of basic propositions.
The first proposition is if you're
unwilling to take any risk, expose
yourself to any risk, you shouldn't
expect to get a return higher than the
risk-free rate. You should be able to
earn what you can earn on a risk-free
investment. But I'll give you an escape
clause. It's called the arbitrage
clause. If you can find a riskless
investment that earns more than a
risk-free rate,
you found a profit machine. You think
what is the chance I have of finding
something like that? Later in this
class, we're going to talk about
arbitrage investment philosophy where
people try to do exactly that. Find a
way to lock in a riskless investment and
earn more than the riskless rate. The
second proposition, in a market that is
efficient, but things are priced the way
they should be, your expected return
will go up only if you're willing to
take on more risk. In other words, your
expected return and risk exposure are
locked at the head. Here again, I'll
give you an escape hatch. The hope of
those who hope to beat the market, and
we'll talk about how this plays out in
market efficiency and inefficiency,
is that you can find a way to invest and
earn a higher return than you should
given the risk you're exposed to. That's
an excess return. So, that's a risk and
return standing point. Let's talk a
little bit about price risk before we
look at the different variations
on measuring risk. Price risk is the RI
is the risk that comes from the price of
your asset moving from period to period.
And when you look at that number, it's
you know you can compute it
statistically as a standard deviation.
So if I gave you the stock prices for a
stock over the last 120 months, you can
compute the standard deviation in
prices. There's a catch though. If your
stock is highly priced, you know what I
mean by highly priced, a $500 stock per
share or $1,000 per share, its standard
deviation in dollar terms is going to be
much greater than if it's a $10 stock.
That's going to make standard deviations
almost impossible to compute. So usually
when people compute price risk measures,
they try to do it on a standardized
basis. You see, what does that mean? You
can look at the percentage return in the
price rather than the dollar change in
the price.
The standard deviation that percentage
return can be compared across different
investments. Not just across stocks,
across bonds and across real assets.
So when we look at standard deviation,
we tend to look at standard deviations
and changes or percentage changes in a
stock. So let's take an example. This is
a single stock Disney from 2008 to 2013.
I collected the prices for the stock. I
also collected dividends. Why? Because
as an investor in Disney, you're going
to get that as an additional return in
the months in which the stock go pays a
dividend. What you see here in the green
line is the Disney stock price. And you
can see that the axis goes from 0 to
100. The stock went from about $30 to
about $65 over the period. It almost
doubled. That's good, right? All I've
done at the red line is taken the
percentage changes in prices every
month.
If I look at the standard deviation in
the price, it's $1247.
I'm not sure what I can do with that
because that is affected by the price
level. But the percentage standard
deviation of 7.64% that you see in
returns, I can compare across stocks,
across investments.
In fact, there's a variant that
financial academics and researchers
sometimes use where instead of looking
at percentage returns, you look at the
log price. You have to trust me on this
one, but log price is very much like a
percentage return. It has better
properties statistically in some ways,
but you're trying to standardize. Again,
that's for an individual stock.
Now, in this graph, I look at all US
stocks versus T- bonds.
In fact, I look at stocks, T- bonds, T-
bills, and corporate bonds. I know this
graph is almost impossible to read
outside of the S&P 500 stocks. And you
can see that stocks have more zigs and
zags, bigger zigs and zags than T- bonds
or T- bills. And you can compute the
standard deviation again in percentage
stock prices, which is about 20%. But
bond price standard deviation is much
lower and TE standard deviation is even
lower.
When we think about risk in investing, I
know this is lazy. We've ended up using
standard deviation and percentage
changes because it's comparable across
investments. So, let's pause and think
about the variance we talked about
before. Downside versus total risk.
Let's start with the obvious. As
investors, nobody lies at night lies
awake at night wondering, you know, what
happened to the stock. The stock doubles
in price. It's downside risk that
creates pain. And so when we think about
risk, we tend to think in terms of
downside risk.
The standard deviations I talked about
look at both sides, right? You can have
a high standard deviation for a stock
that went up 500%. Because the price
variation was high. Standard deviations
look at total risk. And there are people
in fact who argue that that's a problem
with standard deviation. There's a way
in which you can compute the standard
deviation variance only in returns that
fall below the average return or just a
measure of downside risk. So total risk
versus downside risk. And the reason we
often focus on total risk is it turns
out the world doesn't give you freebies.
Then when there's a lot of upside,
there's often a lot of downside. When
there's less upside, there's less
downside. Total risk and downside
standard deviations are very highly
correlated. You can use one as a standin
for the other.
Second contrast, we talked about this
earlier. The risk in the cash flows
versus the risk in the price. If you're
an intrinsic value investor, you buy an
investment for its cash flows. So from
your perspective, you could argue the
way you think about risk is not by
looking at what a market price does
because markets make mistakes, but by
looking at a variance in earnings or
cash flows. We'll come back and discuss
this more when we talk about value
investing because here again it's a
false choice. Most companies which have
high variance earnings and cash flows
will have high variance stock price. But
it's true. Sometimes the two might give
you different signals.
The other problem with with earnings and
cash flows, they get measured four times
a year for US companies. Every time an
earnings report comes out, stock prices
are continuous. They change minute by
minute, hour by hour, and they can be
updated constantly. Cash flow risk
versus price risk. And finally, the
contrast that I think we should spend a
little bit more time on is the risk of a
company standing alone, investment
standing alone as a as opposed to the
risk that it adds to a portfolio. In
fact, we can argue that finance as we
know it was born out of one man Harry
Marow is walking into a library in 19
the early 50s and getting caught up in
this issue of hey why do we think of
risk in terms of a stock alone when in
fact we have portfolios that the risk
add to a portfolio should be the way we
think about risk. Now to see why the two
could be different, let's go back to
what happens when you go from one stock
to two stocks to five stocks to 10
stocks to 50 stocks in your portfolio.
First, each investment becomes a smaller
portion of the portfolio.
So the investment has a bad day or a
good day, the effect on your portfolio
be much smaller.
But here's the other and much more
critical aspect on each of these stocks.
Things can happen that are specific to
the stock, right? good things, bad
things. And the law of large numbers
becomes the mechanism that plays out
across your portfolio. In other words,
if you have 50 stocks, you might have
three stocks where something good
happens, three stocks where something
bad happens, and 44 stocks where nothing
happens. There's an averaging out that
happens over time.
that ladder benefit or the the averaging
out is going to be greater if your
investments don't all if every
investment that you have moves in
proportion to the other investments
there's no benefit but the less they
move together the greater the benefit
this is what we capture with a
correlation across investments
now I can show this benefit very simply
with a statistical effect what I've done
here is looked at what happens the
standard deviation of a portfolio as you
go from one stock to 50 stocks. See that
first line? Nothing happens. You're
saying how come? Because that's a
scenario where the correlation is one.
The stocks move in perfect proportion to
each other. As the correlation
decreases, the benefits to to port to
having a portfolio increase. In fact, at
the limit, if you have 50 uncorrelated
assets, the standard deviation of the
portfolio is only 5%. even though the
individual investments you put in each
headphone this is portfolio magic and
I'll also tell you that if you put 50
stocks together there's almost zero
chance that they will be uncorrelated
with each other have a correlation of
zero but even if they have a correlation
of 6 or8 which is a pretty high
correlation look at the benefits you
still get with a 6 correlation your
standard deviation goes from 40% down to
32%.
That's the benefit of diversification.
So when you think about when when the
when you think about risk here are the b
here's the bottom line. We can disagree
but how to measure risk. Price risk
versus cash flow risk.
We could upside risk versus downside
risk. But to argue that risk doesn't
matter as an investor is foolhardy. Risk
always does matter. And if you have
different investment philosophies, you
can come up with different measures of
risk. If you're a true intrinsic value
investor, you might decide your measure
of risk is cash flow risk and only
downside cash flow risk. Perfectly okay.
If you're a trader, your risk might be
total risk because that's what you think
better fits you and in price.
Every investor has to come up with a
risk measure that fits their way of
thinking about the world. And then
here's I think the part that troubles
investors the more and the reason
they're so reluctant to even measure
risk. Once you measure the risk, you
then have to look at the returns you
earned given that risk and ask yourself,
is this worth it? Is what I'm doing
adding value or should I go back to
doing whatever I did with the rest of my
life and put my investing on autopilot?
You see, what's investing on autopilot?
We'll talk about it. There are ways you
can invest today on autopilot where you
don't have to make those judgments. So
in this session, we've at least in
generic terms talked about risk as both
good and bad, danger plus opportunity.
Talked about the different perspectives
on risk, cash flow versus price, total
versus downside,
portfolio versus standalone. But we have
a foundation. In the next couple of
sessions, we'll take that foundation and
use it to come up with specific ways of
measuring risk both in fixed income
bonds as well as in equities. Thank you
very much for listening
and I'll see you in the next session.